[Musique]
les rangs du sang sur les mains et
contre l audi etc auxquels nous oblige
ayant c'est un mange merde un col canto
des manises musin qui est maintenant
protégé un suisse du sang sur les mains
et olivier ferrand aussi est aujourd hui
le perron et mourront de leur cupidité
[Musique]
c'est vrai que c'est assez violent
c'est vrai que là c'est assez violent
avait pas eu ces images et on les a vus
aujourd'hui martin blaché qu'on voyait
ça vous vous dites ça va trop loin là
bas j'ai l'impression de voir un sketch
de jean marie bigard bienvenue moins
évidemment que ça va beaucoup trop loin
visons aucun sang sur les mains ils ont
fait ce qu'ils pouvaient comme tous les
gouvernements du monde après on peut les
critiquer on peut remettre en question
la stratégie on peut remettre en
question leurs positions mais
l'intention en tout cas je pense n'a
jamais été de nuire à qui que ce soit
s'il vous plaît vous avez opté pour
garde laurent alexandre combat de là on
est parti en plein délire mais vous
n'avez pas montré la partie la pire la
partie la pire c'est quand même quand il
explique que le pass sanitaires c'est
comme l'étoile jaune série drôle encore
la guerre on l'a montré hier
oui mais la dalle est comparé à
passeport vaccinale à passeport
sanitaires et les pcr avec le traitement
des juifs on lui a dit hier encore là
pendant la seconde guerre mondiale on
est en plein délire onyx d'ennemis site
est totalement une adhésion fera donc
son discours est totalement inadmissible
mais moi personnellement c'est pas
bigard que j'en veux le plus c'est aux
gens qui tirent les ficelles derrière
parce que la lan et bigard ils ont
aucune pensée scientifique epidemiology
derrière c'est évidemment alexandra
aurions code ceni c'est là la femme
l'ancien l'ancien sun ce scientifique
qui est à côté de bigard lors de la
cérémonie et qui les excite tous elle
elle tient des propos qui sont des
pourpoints ultra complotistes mais elle
n'a su le jeu personne est derrière elle
elle organise donc des réunions avec la
lan et bigard est derrière bigard voilà
voilà alexandre aurions code est
derrière vous avez bigard qui est qui va
au feu qui est son porte flingues et
c'est absolument scandaleux avec c'est
trop violent courant et ça c'est
inacceptable d'expliquer qu'il faut
qu'un ministre crève d'expliquer que
c'est un assassin alors qu'il se bat
contre une maladie qu'on connaît encore
pas très bien c'est juste honteux
ces gens sont des complotistes fous ces
gens sont des complotistes délirant et
il faut faire attention parce que de
derrière des tels mots de démo si
terrible il pourrait y avoir quelqu'un
qui prend un flingue qui va tuer les
ministres nous c'est à dire que derrière
cette violence verbale pourrait avoir de
l'allégeance politique ni à 40 ans il ya
40 ans en france
il fout on assassiner le patron de
renault oui apprendre à signer en italie
des grands patrons
on a assassiné le premier ministre itri
l'italien et on a assassiné en allemagne
le patron des patrons le le patron du
patronat donc la violence politique elle
peut revenir quand vous avez quelqu'un
comme bigard qui est adoré notamment par
les gilets jaunes qui explique que vers
ans doit crever comme buzek s'est des
assassins eh bien il ya quelqu'un qui
peut prendre un flingue et à les tuer
ses ministres et donc c'est extrêmement
dangereux
on ne doit pas jouer avec la violence
politique elle arrive suffisamment vite
la violence politique pour que des
abrutis comme ça ne soit pas laissée
seule avec des mots qui peuvent tuer
parce que les mots de cet abruti peuvent
tuer expliqué que le ministre doit
crever c'est une incitation à les lui
foute une balle entre les deux yeux
il ya suffisamment de cinglé dans les
rues pour pas les exciter un peu plus
donc digard il faut le boycotter il faut
absolument ne plus l'écouter et il faut
que les gens raisonnables qui sont
autour de lui il m'explique qui déconne
à à plein tube et que c'est inacceptable
ce qu'il fait parce que c'est
inacceptable d'un point de vue
allez politique alors richard boutry
vous étiez à présent la manif
qu'est ce que vous répondez à ça ce que
vous étiez alors vous savez sur marine
et je le dis c'est vraiment un ami c'est
mon ami ni si on voit les jeux eux
là dessus je trouve ça et voilà j'ai bu
des propos c'est vrai que c'est excessif
au niveau des propos c'est une galerie
que ces voix-là sais c'est que c'est
compliqué de deux acceptent voilà là
c'est vrai que je pense qu'il s'est fait
influencer
je suis un peu d'accord avec monsieur
alexandre se trouve que là dessus s'est
fait influencer que là il a été trop
loin là dessus après sûr c'est sur ces
thèses
voilà il pense ce qu'il veut chacun pour
ce qui ne et c'est vrai que moi il
m'arrive très souvent de ne pas être
d'accord avec son mari sans reste
néanmoins amis mais là c'est vrai que
c'est assez violent
et quand tu crèves c'est c'est quand
même il ya le cas ce week-end
l'incitation au meurtre
c'est violent qu'est ce que jean-marie
voit la ccc il est comme ça il mais je
pense qu'ils en pensent il pense pas un
mot de ce qu'il dit alors j'ai trois
choses à dire d'abord les assassins ce
ton ce sont eux les assassins ceux qui
depuis un an et demi nous [ __ ] des
prisons joue avec nos nerfs joue avec
nous juhasz nos enfants qui aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui veulent faire vacciner nos
enfants qui aujourd'hui nous fout des
masques à longueur de journée qui
aujourd'hui nous emprisonnent qui
aujourd'hui nous empêche de vivre et
anti aujourd'hui nous empêche de voir
nos grands parents si aujourd'hui nous
empêche de vivre notre propre vie j'ai
cinq enfants
s'il y en a deux qui sont ici dans les
dents dans les coulisses finir ces
gosses ne peuvent pas vivre depuis un an
et demi vous trouvez ça normal en raison
de quoi aux raisons de quoi dit que moi
alors maintenant on y voir le taux de
mortalité il est un film ici je les
infimes le taux de mortalité on le sait
et sharon est dans une dictature
aujourd'hui
d'accord j'étais présentateur sachet de
lait j'ai été présentateur et vous le
savez sur france télévisions je prends
le soir 3 j'ai toujours été super bien
noté personnel tu as dit que je délirais
d'amazon mais c'est vrai exploit au lion
code il se permet de dire cette espèce
de crétin en face de moi
il reste à venir qui sait cette femme
c'est la généticienne numéro un qui est
aussi un erreur vrai c'est tout c'est
rff en bas d'une colline
il est pas du tout elle était de savoir
qui est beaucoup par son chef de
paraître pas rater simplement et c'est
cette fois la leçon après s'être essayée
et pointer dans votre vie des autres
enfants
les pays qui connaissent à faire on
envoie à l'abattoir mais c'est
scandaleux ce que vous faites vous êtes
tous cas de co2 contre l'autisme de
conspirationnistes d'abord un
journaliste il doit douter de ce que du
gouvernement puis jhen ou traiter blaché
on est face à ses ennuis je me dois de
traiter d'assassin vous dire un truc me
l'avait pas moins demandés si vous
voulez on lui a demandé s'il voulait
faire vacciner ses enfants il a dit non
j'ai vu ça justement de venir vous
n'avez aucun droit de nous traiter
d'abord je veux pas du tout de même sont
correctement ok si vous ne prenez aucun
de respect pour bull
l'intelligence artificielle garder là
pour vous allez allez pourquoi vous
vivez en belgique aujourd'hui c'est pour
vous entendre avec le monde et surtout
les pertes mais ici vous allergiques
encore souplesse aux classes et stendhal
pas dans ces conditions c'est des
rations juste richard boutry qu'est ce
que vous dites aux gens qui vous disent
c'est pareil dans le monde entier
kleibrink pourquoi alors alors alors
justement grâce à cyril c'est une très
très bonne question mais moi j'ai un
camping car je vis dans un camping car
j'ai fait cinquante mille kilomètres
cette année j'étais dans toute l'europe
pour voir la réalité du terrain et celle
pour vous décrire la télévision et
schémas passé pour savoir gérer
présentateur télé pendant 25 ans donc je
sais ce que c'est et j'ai été voir
j'étais en allemagne j'ai été au
luxembourg j'ai été dans les pays du
nord
j'ai été partout j'étais en espagne à
madrid j'ai vécu à madrid la batoude est
ouvert le paie toujours
j'ai dit je crée le gall madrid oui a
ouvert depuis toujours que tu puisses à
madame pourra pas toujours monsieur
peut-être pas toujours vraiment vraiment
juste parce que vous êtes beaucoup
énervé parce que moi je suis comme vous
je ça fait peur de vaccins vous savez
excusez moi je vous coupe juste un
moment juste une dernière phrase il
savait que 80 % des français pensent
comme nous mais les instituts de sondage
et tout ça ce sont des proches de
l'accord et c'est pour ça c'est ce temps
d'accord avec vous c'est que vous dites
qu'on va vacciner nous nos enfants comme
des bêtes
oui cinq enfants oui vous savez qui sont
vaccinées vos enfants déjà pour aller à
l'école au centre aéré à la crèche
ils sont vaccinés vous savez combien ils
ont dans leurs amis de vaccins dans le
besoin de vos enfants en 11 matchs avec
des boks a conduit recul mais vraiment
vous pouvez savoir que cela c'est un
faux pas des injections mais non mais
c'est des indications bcc 11 vaccins
entre 0 et 2 rax à 11 à vacciner si vous
voulez la liste de noms mais sans
laisser hors sujet mais c'est leur
suggérer pourquoi je vous dis pourquoi
ce sujet vous dit des bêtises excusez
moi la fcc des vaccins qui sont là
depuis des années qui ont été testées
petit depuis des années voilà ce que ce
que dénonce aujourd'hui richard boutry
et au niveau libre c'est que le vaccin
on n'a pas assez de recul dessus comme
certaines personnes peuvent le dire une
bourgade a passé le veut le stade 3
cyril aucun à face et leur statut est né
trois fois dans le monde
la sortie de gens marcher droit mais le
3e qu'il faudra faire il fallait faire
un inventaire de tout ce qui s'est passé
depuis un an je suis d'accord pour ça je
pense qu'il faut être ouvert à ça il
faut pas s'insulter je veux dire que
vous avez sur qu'est ce qui a été fait à
la voix parfois je ne critique le
premier confinement je pense qu'elle
était trop stricte mais après on peut le
justifier aussi le deuxième je pense
qu'il est peut-être un tout petit peu
moins justifiable mais il a aussi été
plus léger je pense qu'on doit discuter
de ça enfin c'est vrai qu'on a le droit
de faire un inventaire bien sûr c'est
pas sérieux quand tu sais ce que ça a
coûté à chacun et faut pas qu'à chaque
fois que quelqu'un fasse un demande
d'inventaire on se met à l'insulter et
ça veut dire que c'est un fou dangereux
après ce qu'a fait jean marie bigard
s'est pas demandé un droit d'inventaire
s'est demandé la mort du ministre de la
santé et de l'ancienne miss de la santé
donc qu'on fasse un il faudra le faire
de toute façon moi je fais partie de
ceux qui pensent qu'on pourra pas
simplement balayer tout ce qui s'est
passé comme si de rien n'avait été et
continuer parce qu'en plus il ya des
sujets centraux qui sont sortis pendant
cette crise et qui vont ressortir plus
tard la place de la personne âgée
le client avec le digital la sensibilité
avec nos données
le sujet de l'industrie pharmaceutique
et bat allons-y on peut y aller quel
sont les conflits d'intérêts qu'est ce
qu'un conflit d'intérêts est ce qu'on
peut vivre dans une société sans
conflits d'intérêts voilà c'est ça les
vrais sujets et il faudra le faire donc
vous avez le droit de le demander mais
pas la manière de jean marie bigard ce
serait dommage de le faire olive bah en
fait jean marie bigard il a représenté
la colère des français aujourd'hui par
rapport à toutes les incohérences et
toutes les fautes
en fait qui ont été faites par le ca il
émeut tout à fait le combat en estonie
jean-marie sien c'est un pote tu sais
c'est bon vraiment ces messieurs les
intimes voilà je l'adorais type super
humain c'est sûr mais picard coeur comme
ça on tapote générique rêve c'est c'est
un point qu'on voit là c'est juste dans
les mots voilà c'est ce que je veux
juste finir la colère comprend ce que je
veux expliquer c'est qu'à force les gens
ils n'en peuvent plus ils en ont marre
donc on arrive à des excès de colère
comme ça et c'est tout à fait logique
les gens aujourd'hui vous savez ce
qu'ils veulent ils veulent sauver leur
liberté vous savez ce que c'est ça vous
savez ce que c'est pour des êtres
humains de sauver leur liberté qui soit
par nash et entend parler du pass
sanitaires on entend parler de la
vaccination pour les enfants
vous êtes vous imaginez aujourd'hui en
le gouvernement vous vous on les
récupère tpourquoi et voudrait le faire
ces sacs mais il est déjà en train de le
faire a toujours critiquer ce
gouvernement d'être trop libéral
pourquoi le gouvernement aussi libéral
voudrait vous en ai déjà dit il ya des
gens qui disent pour vous répondre
richard boutry viadeo qui dit dit à ce
monsieur que si on était dans une
dictature on ne peut pas dire qu'un
ministre droit crevé voilà là même où
ils en étaient venus à les plateaux télé
les venir de le dire ce maillot et
télévision je peux vous dire que je
connais très bien le système médiatique
le ciet médiatique aujourd'hui n'est
réservée qu'aux gens du pouvoir aux gens
proches du pouvoir et les journalistes
qui sont en place je parle pas de vous
parce que vous avez une certaine forme
d'éthique une certaine liberté d'action
et c'est pour ça que vous avez public
que vous méritez merci je veux dire il
ya beaucoup et vous le savez cyril sur
les chaînes de télévision qui n'invite
pas des gens comme moi parce qu'ils sont
trop dangereux parce qu'ils ont trop de
rêver aux mises entre deux mais je joue
entre 2 répartie je voulais ça fragilise
les types comme lui qui sont tous les
jours à la télévision sur toutes les
chaînes
je suis désolé franchement c'est pas le
veau terrible alain de gens qui disent
moi je le vois sur les réseaux y
apprennent qu'ils sont d'accord et vous
après il ya des questions et hier les
gendarmes des changes il ya des gens qui
disent interne drama % sur le fond
auprès d'accor et vous la forme problème
voilà un excès de colère benausse aurait
erré et non mais sacré c'est un cri du
coeur comme tous ces gens en ont
ras-le-bol aujourd'hui j'ai devant moi
je suis le français moyen
et c'est pour ça que j'ai plus j'ai
toujours utilisé une meilleure audience
à la télévision pourquoi parce que je
suis con cernant colonisés à france
télévisions concernant c'est à dire que
représente le peuple et moi je prend le
pouls sur le tirage je sens la
température et les gens sont fous
furieux en france et sans le dis jamais
sur les chaînes de télévision peut-être
chez vous et vous me donnez l'occasion
ce soir de le dire tu peux être l'un des
premiers à le dire que les français
aujourd'hui son magie rue majorité
gladio ni volé plusieurs fois ici c'est
vrai que la colère montante et la colère
monte la colère - et dernier truc est là
que je suis désolé je suis allé voir
mais voilà mon classement vous savez
celui qu'a alors c'est ça enfin le
militaire oui il nous a dit aujourd'hui
vous savez combien de personnes qui ont
signé son site
il a cent trente mille personnes il a 26
mille militaires qu'ils eurent chi chi
chi le rejoignent là aujourd'hui il ya
un courant fédérateur un ours hume c'est
ce mouvement de contestation aujourd'hui
on a une vraie légitimité auprès du
peuple puisse convenir et les instituts
de sondage qui sont tenus par les
proches de macron aujourd'hui disent des
conneries à longueur de journée nous
étions pas sans fil à une élections
qu'elles entament l'année prochaine
l'univers elle aura lieu ouais mais je
pense quelle va être la seule peut-être
pensé vous pensez quoi
là dessus moi je pense très clairement
qu'aujourd'hui
d'abord un ils gagnent du temps 2 comme
les régionales les rasets repoussé donc
c'est pas lui qui va annoncer parce que
ce sera la révolution que les élections
n'ont pas lieu c'est l'europe qui va
venir écouter vraiment les conditions ne
sont pas riches mais après juste un peu
non alors ça veut rien dire mais sachez
que la france va être présidente de
l'europe à partir de janvier
voilà donc on sera président de l'europe
d'aujourd'hui mais ça richard jeu je
peux je sens qu'il ya plus fragiles si
on va avoir lieu par les décalages en
passant le monde sait qu'ils sont fait
vacciner ses débuts on est des abrutis
comment comment vous voyez ça en fait on
est juste c'est à dire il ya beaucoup de
catch peta est aussi dire qu'il ya des
gens qui ont pas de discernement banon
la planète
ça va ça ne soit pas des cons les gens
qui regardent les chaînes de télévision
qui légua va langueur de journée de la
connerie et de saloperies et ces gens là
malheureusement non pas le discernement
nécessaire pour pouvoir et bigard le fer
jr fermement vous retrouve à réfléchir
par eux-mêmes ans qui passe me direz que
je vais trouver la vérité en offrant là
dessus j'étais à paris j'étais à paris
avec le redire encore avec 120 coach
j'étais à paris samedi
je suis parti la nuit j'ai fait la route
pour aller à annecy où il y avait 900
personnes sur lac d'annecy et je peux
vous dire que les gens là-bas sur place
sont particulièrement éclairé on vous
parlait des plateaux de télévision à
paris la réalité française dans les
campagnes c'est tout autre c'est quoi la
solution pour vous olive olive est riche
à 100 le vaccin c'est quoi la solution
aujourd'hui pour nous c'est que c'est
une plante émis si vous voulez qu'ils
qui fait quasiment à le nombre de morts
et vous allez me confirmer le nombre de
morts aujourd'hui tenez vous bien depuis
un an sur les chiffres officiels du
ministère de la santé le nombre de morts
dus qu'aux vide du haut comité aux quais
de combien 17000 à 17000 dû simplement
qu vide avec le co vienne égale 50 mille
le le parc des princes qui est à côté la
constance du parc des princes est-ce que
vous pensez que pour dix sept mille
personnes mordues coville est la bonne
est obligé de fermer tous ces corps de
métiers
ces jo sur la corde au cou icha et qui
ce retrait de crever la bouche ouverte
mécha jeu c'est pas possible c'est riche
valu le trophée souplesse va aller dans
votre sens imaginons ce que vous dites
nous un complot kelly l'intérêt alors on
parle que de la france ça du président
de la république emmanuel bach mon cas
des échéances la débouchés merci et qui
vont déjà des assurances pendant l'année
prochaine puisqu'il ya des élections
présidentielles quel est son intérêt de
stopper l'économie c'est bien de voir
des gens dans la rue en septembre et
étranglé financièrement
voilà de voir des gens qui se font chier
et des jeunes qui disent on n'a plus
d'avenir ne voir des suicides de voir
une insécurité montée quel est pour vous
l'intérêt de faire tout ça lors des
manuels macro sur nous dans le timing là
qui est compliqué pour lui cyril la
terrible
enfin il est évident la mairie on l'a on
l'a placé qu'il a placé ce type là qui
sort de nulle part n'a jamais été
solidaire de l'état non je parle de
macron qui n'a jamais été la sarthe sur
les terrains de france qui n'a eu aucun
mandat il a été placé ici avec un cahier
des charges précis où il remplit le
cahier des charges
il est là pour serrer la vis au maximum
et pour nourrir tous les riches qui
aujourd'hui vivent ici c'est la vie
c'est vrai nous a donné de récré pour
les couloirs pour l'été cyril il nous a
donné accès politesse et syndrome de
stockholm pas dire finie c'est dangereux
si le géôliers devient vraiment la
personne la plus attirante qui soit mais
vous répondez à la question
répondez moi j'ai été regardé par
curiosité intellectuelle vos vidéos et
dans vos vidéos vous d expliquer c'est à
dire tous les fondamentaux qu'on tape
concon complotistes à dire que les
profiteurs pour répondre à la question
de série d'après vous c'est alors de ce
qu'on appelle ce que vous appelez vous
un délire total donc on serait tous dans
une sorte de délire total tous qu'il
n'existe pas ce sont les rothschild
comme par hasard la finance l'industrie
pharmaceutique et vous dit qu'on est en
train de nous faire subir un plomb
génocidaire ne croyez pas que vous
n'êtes que là vous êtes coupé mes
délires et appelons génocidaire ça
marche mais je pense est maladroit le
pense et moi je suis un peu quand même
content à vous dit keith aulie 7000
morts faut savoir soit 6,1 g n'osait
rien que difficilement renier
errant ont fait passer un génocide sont
la défense yeux ça gêne aussi pour
l'industrie vous comprenez ou pas vous
êtes énarques et hsbc qui connaissent
j'ai aussi porter ces gens qui soit un
projet d'accord il ya un nombre de gens
vous vous travaillez vous vous êtes payé
par qui au point où on peut le savoir
non mais vous vous voyez les gens les
commerçants les gens qui sont qui veut
expliqué richard c'est qu'on en train de
nous asservir petit à petit c'est quand
même la vérité qu'on est en train de
nous enlever des libertés c'est quand
même la vérité en pleine pandémie en
pleine pandémie comme dit le
gouvernement
on a passé la réforme chômage vous
imaginez quand même la réforme c'est des
apl
c'est une zone totale était avant non
c'est pas avant c'était en planeur même
à rantigny excuse encore lui excuse moi
tu es mal renseigné regarde s'est passé
pendant d'ailleurs va sera actif le 1er
juillet la réforme chômage gâteau shen
messieurs vous démontre macro comme
sabrer vous inquiétez pas on va s'en
occuper tout ça et j'espère que tous les
contestataires de france auront un
candidat citoyens aux élections alors
courage et les dépouilles étaient ces
gens leur fille brune évolué et richard
boutry aujourd'hui il ya des élections
l'année prochaine
vers quel candidat vous pouvez vous
tourner et o'neal n'avait pas de
candidat qui correspondra à vos idées
alors oui il ya aucun candidat des
jeunes gens tombent pas dans l'autre à
leur milieu politique parce qu'on pense
à juste titre qu'ils font tous partie du
système et qui donne rien accroché alors
soit tous les politiques actuelles c'est
pareil comme disait richard gere carnet
de révélations vous attendez quelques
uns il ya des choses qui vont arriver il
ya des choses qui vont se passer dans
l'est dans les semaines à venir
j'espère qu'on aura un vrai candidat
citoyens l'écoutent du peuple du peuple
parce que normalement le président est
là pour ça et c'est pas ce qui se passe
et tout ce que je vois moi c'est une
précarité qui continue de grandir à
grands pas personne ne le sait remercier
le dire alors au niveau local est
toujours dit sur son ghetto oui et si on
l'a toujours dit à des politiques et mes
possibilités tient de quel moment on va
être d'accord de dire que on a un
président qui est là depuis quatre ans
et que les gens continuent à voir de
plus en plus de moins de liberté moins
d'argent et ce qui s'en suit c'est que
quand même il est mauvais vous êtes
content
vous devez être payés par lui vous avez
des yeux c'est dans la définition assez
horrible votre regard directeur sens
éméché plaît merci vous avez
complètement parano ou in on est
toujours avec vous arrêtez de dire que
je suis payé par macron qu'est-ce qui
vous bien si c'est beau macron ça sera
des sociétés pharmaceutiques ou des
enfants n'ont plus d'argent au dessus
parce que pour dire de telles conneries
comme vous avez dit et d'ailleurs oui si
vous voulez d'ailleurs j'ai rectifié ce
que vous arrêtez s'il vous plaît la télé
n'a s'il vous plaît je vais rectifier ce
que vous avez dit 'ne boycotter surtout
pas jean marie bigard et j'en appelle à
tous les citoyens à qui nos regards
soutenez-le parce que moi lui c'est
quelqu'un qui a des couilles comme il
dit au moins il ajouté
oui on est tous ces derniers vous êtes
intéressé chez le dernier mot qui a tâté
ac j'ai eu jean marie justement au
téléphone juste avant pour venir lui ai
posé la question je suis et ce que je
dois y aller à cette émission je
connaissais pas plus que ça j'ai
interviewé sur france soir ce que vous
savez que j'ai relancé france soir je
fais quand même une démission qui ont
dépassé le million il m'a dit qu'il
recevait aujourd'hui l'appel d'une
majorité des maires de france pour venir
se produire sur place ils hésitent à
l'olympia mi juin
c'est déjà bourré c'est complet il faut
vivre continuer à le voir un incident à
lierre mérite vraiment le succès qu'il a
il a rempli ca de france il
je voudrais toujours d'éléments lourds à
jésus je lui ai dit craig voilà jean
marc ysaye voilà sur le voit 10 kg jean
marie et ce à quoi sert il sait ce
monsieur qui appellent à boycotter mais
c'est monsieur kenna en passant chez le
mérite
vous méritez cours en train de rebondir
aux français qui vous font confiance à
ce que vous même un des leurs oui mais
on est tous des menteurs on est des
complotistes on est des fous on est
surtout d éveiller mener d éveiller mc
lane c'est vous monsieur et vous donne
un gros mytho ma wii et vous vous êtes
un âne et je peux vous dire qu'ils
appellent à la mort à la mort couler
penser à la mort physique accord